[Music]
the county hosting its spring job fair
today at the convention center over 100
employers seeking applicants with
turnout in the thousands many people
even hired on the spot madison kimbrough
was there talking to hopefuls about the
process and why it was so important for
them to show up today she joins us live
several people still trying to get their
feet on the ground after losing so much
during the pandemic and with prices
rising everywhere the need for higher
paying jobs is a must
friday's spring job fair started at 9am
and lasted until 2pm and offered job
seekers the opportunity to meet with
over a hundred companies looking to fill
over 13 000 positions while the need for
higher pay is on everyone's mind the
need to fill positions continues to be
in high demand employers like caesar's
entertainment mgm resorts international
golden and boyd gaming were all in
attendance along with medical companies
like sdmi positions such as bank tellers
security specialists casino workers
custodial work jobs in law enforcement
registered nurses front desk and
receptionist work and district teaching
positions were all offered here's what
some hopefuls who attended the fair
today had to say
basically looking for another job and
trying to be able to get my own
apartment or house better than what i'm
getting now because right now i'm only
getting
12 an hour the longest lines were pretty
much at the casinos but
the medical was just as long
so it was a tie between both of them
fortunately for several people they
walked out of the fair employed as the
lowest paying wage offered at the fair
for most positions was 18 dollars an
hour employment professionals were also
on hand to help with resumes and provide
career coaching
today's turnout overall was a success
for both attendees and employers with
over 6 000 people in attendance and more
than 450 people were hired on site
reporting live madison kimbrough live
local now
thanks madison a new state report says
nevada added 5400 jobs last month las
vegas saw the fastest growth as tourists
especially international visitors return
one of the key points of the report
actually involves reno the state says
employment there is at an all-time high
we continue tracking the job market for
you we've put together a list of
companies hiring and links to apply it's
at 8newsnow.com just click on the job
board tab